do you guys sit down and prepare for a
talk show do you
guys consciously say we're going on cold
bear let's do this hunk of our act well
i mean i think that i i have always
personally
overly prepared you know i've sent in
like 18 pages to letterman it gives me
the confidence
to go out there and say i am prepared i
don't know what's going to happen he may
be off i might maybe off but at least i
gave it the college try so there are
some times like even with colbert last
night we planned a few things but we
never got to them but we also know
last night we did colbert but selena was
on with us so that's three people and we
know look we can't start doing
routines and bits for the third person
there it's exclusive marty you would
send letterman
18 pages of jokes and ideas and things
that you wanted to accomplish
was it your goal to go out there and say
i am going to be the best damn talk show
guest on the planet i think it was uh
new york magazine or something they
named you the greatest talk show guest
of all time were you aware of that
um
sure
i'll tell you one thing it makes me
aware of it
no no listen but i but i think in
general howard it's the idea that you
can never control
the finished product you can't when you
make a movie
um
you know you could be working with a
[ __ ] director
no no but really and you go
i this won't be any good but what i can
do is that i can
give every
v version of the take
fast slow big small and i can weasel a
couple of extra ones because everyone
loves me so i say can i have a freedom
take ah should we let marty have a
freedom and they give me then i go home
and i think this [ __ ] will pick the
wrong take but i'm going to toast myself
with champagne because i did everything
i could do so it's kind of
you're talking about is it is you want
to go out there and kill and be the best
guest ever but i think it's the opposite
i mean for me
i don't want a bomb
right well yes that's really it's
defensive you know to have material and
work on it and talk talk about it
stephen you would go on carson and do a
routine like fly deeney where your
magician and your act is you pull things
out of your fly did you ever do that in
a club anywhere beforehand or did you go
on i
rehearsed that
bit so much i did it in a rehearsal hall
i
did it for some um
you know private charity things
and then i thought the only way i'm
gonna get good at this is to book myself
for two weeks in atlantic city and i
opened for the smothers brothers and i
did this seven minute act every night
for for two weeks and i told my age and
i said look we can't
promote me
because it's a cheat i'm only going to
do seven minutes so you promote the
smothers brothers and then maybe in tiny
little letters or something so as i'm
driving to atlantic city
i see a billboard
steve martin
and i thought oh
no but anyway i did it every night and
then i kind of retired it and then
carson was retiring himself and he said
would you do fly dini because he was a
magician and like that sort of thing
what i'm obsessed with is the two of you
the the different reaction to johnny
carson steve actually became friends
with johnny johnny respected steve blah
blah blah
marty you were asked to do the tonight
show you turned it down a bunch of times
because you were so intimidated by
johnny carson when i finally did it
he was so
fantastic
and so loose and so encouraging it was
like a dream so i did it in that four
years remaining i did it nine times
i loved the um the time you were on with
johnny that that first time and i love
that betty davis is sitting there and
she's real old at that point and
and it's i can almost feel like you're
dying to do a betty davis impression
because she goes do you do me and she
shoots you will look like a
condescending look like i did i said i
went to her and i said well you're not
that easy to do
and she said well then skip it yeah i
didn't know who i was she thought that's
the way i spoke who is in touch with
dave letterman you guys have done so
many letterman appearances marty you
said you always felt like that was where
you were very comfortable on a talk show
because you felt like he was like a peer
and it was the cool show to do steve i
suspect you're very fond of dave as well
yes absolutely
yeah you've done the show many many
times are you guys in touch with him um
do do you do you feel that the the talk
shows have the same gravitas are you
missing these guys like johnny carson
and david letterman well we missed them
because they were great
yeah uh you were in touch with them
were they i i'm not because i never know
well i guess i have an email i do i have
dinners when i'm in town with paul and
dave and i will have a dinner i'm kind
of with him like maybe you say you are
with me i feel a little
intimidated and scared
you know what doesn't mean he scares me
too
no but howard the amazing thing about
david
is like that steve or tom hanks if he
he'd say the same thing
you if you killed on letterman
you were the happiest human being you
could be for a week
yes it was i agree greatest feeling in
the world because we admired him and
loved him so much and if he laughed
what better moment could that be